CATHERINE DRENNAN: One
of the big challenges
of a large lecture is having the
graduate student TAs be really
an integral part of this.
And I think if the grad
students TAs are not
that excited about this teaching
assignment, it's not so good.
You want to have this sense
of enthusiasm and energy.
So one of the problems
I had when I was first
starting with this is that
this TA assignment was not
the most popular.
So when the grad students are
coming in in their first year,
there are organic
chemistry grad students
and they want to teach
organic chemistry.
And there are physical
chemistry students
who want to teach
thermo and kinetics.
Biochem students want
to teach biochemistry,
and inorganic
chemistry students want
to teach inorganic chemistry.
So who is there for
general chemistry?
And so often, it would be
the booby prize assignment
to get stuck in that class,
and there might be a feeling
like, oh, I got stuck because
I wasn't the organic chemistry
professor's first choice.
So I wanted to change
all that because to me,
teaching freshmen in
freshman chemistry
is the most fun teaching ever.
So I knew there
were grad students
out there that could engage
and agree with me that this
is going to be a lot of fun.
I admit, it's more work than
all of those other courses,
but it also can be more fun.
So I thought, we just need
to get the right people in
and I need to educate
them about what
this experience can be like.
So I decided to once the
students were accepted
to come into MIT, I would
send them an information
packet about how they could be
part of this exciting teaching
opportunity, and I made
it glossy and pretty
and sent it to them
and asked them to apply
to be part of the class.
And so we got some
wonderful applications.
I got a great group of people
to be part of this class.
So instead of being like,
oh no, I have to do this,
they're like, yes,
freshman chemistry.
And we brought them in early,
and I got to know the group.
We had extra TA training
in the beginning.
And t-shirts, and by
the time we started,
everyone knew each other.
And it was an opportunity,
also, for the TAs
to make friends because they're
first year graduate students
and so they get to know other
first year grad students
and they build a
sense of team as well.
So for many years now when
we've been really doing this--
having this extra TA training
and applications to be part
of the class-- we've
started the semester
with a group of people
who are just ready to go
and really excited about
being part of that.
And I think that has had such a
wonderful impact on the course
as well.
They see this
whole teaching team
that really want
to be there and are
excited about this opportunity
and care about each
and every one of those students.
And the comments that
I've gotten later,
both from the students and
also sometimes from parents,
that their child in
their freshman year
really felt a connection
as part of this class
and had this TA just
checking in on them, not
just about this class, but about
how they were doing overall.
And it was a support
system that went
beyond the teaching
of chemistry, which
made me really very happy.